SEE YOU LATER.
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO "TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT."
IF THERE IS ONE LESSON OF THIS
WEEKEND'S "MARCH FOR OUR LIVES,"
IT'S THAT ENDING VIOLENCE IN
AMERICA IS EASY.
SO EASY THAT EVEN CHILDREN KNOW
HOW TO DO IT.
ALL THAT STAND BETWEEN THE
BROKEN COUNTRY WE LIVE AND PEACE
FOR THE FUTURE IS A SMALL GROUP
OF EVIL PEOPLE MOSTLY
REPUBLICANS.
AS A PARKLAND STUDENT NOTED
THERE ARE SICK F-ERS OUT THERE
WHO WANT TO SELL MORE GUNS AND
MURDER MORE CHILDREN AND GET
REELECTED.
HIS SCHOOL MATE AGREED.
IF YOU TAKE MONEY FROM THE NRA
YOU HAVE CHOSEN DEATH.
IN THE NRA WAS NOT BLINDLY
COMMITED TO KILLING CHILDREN AND
ENJOY MURDER FOR ITS OWN SAKE,
WE WOULD NOT HAVE SCHOOL
SHOOTINGS IN THE FIRST PLACE.
SPEAKERS OF THE MARCH TOLD US
THAT AND THE MEDIA AMPLIFIED
THAT MESSAGE AND FORMED A RING
AROUND THE ACTIVITIES.
AS BEN WHITE PUT IT.
THE SICKENING EFFORTS TO SLIME,
UNDERMINE AND DEHUMANIZE HE'S
YOUNG PEOPLE BETRAYS AN ENORMOUS
AMOUNT OF FEAR.
IN OTHER WORDS, SHUT UP AMERICA
AND DON'T ASK QUESTIONS.
THE KIDS KNOW WHAT THEY ARE
DOING?
DO THEY KNOW?
FOX.COM RAN THIS STORY.
I HAVE COVERED GUN VIOLENCE FOR
YEARS AND THE SOLUTIONS ARE NOT
A BIG MYSTERY.
WRITTEN BY GERMAN LOPEZ.
HE IS STILL IN HIS 20s.
I HAVE COVERED GUN VIOLENCE FOR
YEARS MAY BE AN OVER-STATEMENT.
BUT LOPEZ APPROACHED THIS
SUBJECT WITH THE SELF-CONFIDENCE
OF A RESEARCH SCIENTIST WADING
IN DATA.
LOPEZ SAID AMERICA NEEDS
AUSTRALIA'S BUY BACK PROGRAM
PAIRED WITH THE SERIOUS BAN ON
SPECIFIC FIREARMS.
INCLUDING ALL SEMI-AUTOMATIC
WEAPONS.
THERE ARE MORE THAN 100 MILLION
OF THOSE IN THE UNITED STATES
AND THE MAJORITY ARE IN THE
BEDROOM CLOSETS OF LAW-ABIDING
AMERICANS.
HOW WOULD WE TAKE ALL OF THOSE
GUNS?
SOMEBODY WOULD HAVE TO GO
DOOR-TO-DOOR TO TAKE THEM BY
FORCE AND ARREST ANYONE WHO
RIFTS.
IN THE NAME OF ENDING GUN
VIOLENCE, PEOPLE WOULD BE SHOT
TO DEATH.
WHO WILL DO IT?
LOCAL POLICE?
THE FBI, DELTA FORCE?
GERMAN LOPEZ OF FOX DID NOT
VOLUNTEER FOR THAT JOB HIMSELF.
HE BLAMED THE NRA FOR BLOCKING
THE WHOLE IDEA.
QUOTE:
WAIT, WE HAVE NEWS HERE.
THE SUPREME COURT IS ALSO IN THE
POCKET OF THE NRA.
IS THERE EVIDENCE OF THAT?
WHICH JUSTICES ARE TAKING GUN
MONEY OR HE JUST THROWING OUT
THAT CLAIM BECAUSE ALL DESCENT
PEOPLE KNOW THE NRA EVIL.
WHY GET HUNG UP ON DETAILS?
THIS IS THE PROBLEM WITH LETTING
CHILDREN WRITE NEWS STORIES.
THE ARTICLES TEND TO BE DUMB AND
DISHONEST AND REINFORCE THE
FANTASY THAT COMPLEX PROBLEMS
HAVE SIMPLE SOLUTIONS.
IN REAL LIFE NOTHING IS SIMPLE.
WE DON'T KNOW WHY THE NUMBER OF
SCHOOL SHOOTINGS HAS RISEN.
THIS SELF-RIGHTEOUS KIDS
SCREAMING AT YOU OVER THE
WEEKEND ARE NOT HELPING.
ERICA THOMAS JOINS US TONIGHT.
THANKS FOR COMING ON.
WHAT DO YOU THINK WOULD HAPPEN
IF WE TRIED TO CONFISCATE
ASSAULT WEAPONS FROM LAW-ABIDING
AMERICANS?
>> WELL, IT'S ABOUT HOW PEOPLE
WILL RESPOND.
WHAT HAPPENED BACK IN 1994.
WE HAD A BAN ON ASSAULT RIFLES.
MASS SHOOTINGS WENT DOWN BY 43%.
WE WANT THOSE TO GO DOWN.
>> Tucker: DIDN'T COLUMBINE TAKE
PLACE DURING THE ASSAULT WEAPONS
BAN AND THE OVERALL RATE REMAIN
UNCHANGED?
>> YOU ARE RIGHT ABOUT COTUM
BIN.
-- COLUMBINE.
I SAID 43% WENT DOWN.
>> Tucker: THE CLINTON JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT WAS REQUIRED TO STUDY
THE FACTS.
THE DEATH RATE BY FIREARMS DID
NOT DECLINE OVER THAT 10 YEAR
PERIOD.
NO LIVES WERE SAVED.
DOESN'T THAT GIVE YOU PAUSE?
>> NO TDOESN'T.
WHEN I THINK ABOUT 2004 WHEN
CONGRESS LIFTED THAT BAN AND
MASS SHOOTINGS WENT UP OVER
200%.
THOSE ARE THE NUMBERS.
MASS SHOOTINGS WENT UP.
>> Tucker: THE MURDER RATE
DIDN'T MOVE AT ALL.
OKAY, THOSE ARE THE NUMBERS.
WHAT DO YOU THINK WOULD HAPPEN
IF LAW ENFORCEMENT PUSHED BY
DEMOCRATIC POLITICIANS TRIED TO
TAKE THE GUNS FROM LAW-ABIDING
AMERICANS?
WHAT DO YOU THINK THE EFFECT
WOULD BE?
>> I AM NOT TALKING ABOUT TAKES
GUNS FROM LAW-ABIDING CITIZENS.
I AM TALKING ABOUT A BAN ON
ASSAULT RIFLE.
WHAT WAR DO WE NEED ASSAULT
RIFLES?
[OVERLAPPING TALKING].
>> Tucker: I DON'T WANT TO ARGUE
WITH YOU.
HERE'S THE LEGISLATION YOU
SUPPORTED IN GEORGIA.
I AM QUOTING FROM THE
LEGISLATION: THE GEORGIA BUREAU
OF INVESTIGATIONS SHALL SEIZE
AND TAKE POSSESSION OF ANY
ASSAULT WEAPON.
THAT'S NOT VOLUNTARY.
THAT'S MANDATORY.
YOU HAVE HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS
OF PEOPLE IN YOUR STATE WHO OWN
WEAPONS YOU SAY ARE ASSAULT
WEAPONS.
ARE YOU WORRIED THAT SOMEONE
MIGHT GET KILLED IF ONE LAW
ENFORCEMENT COMES AND SAYS WE
ARE TAKING YOUR GUN AWAY?
WHAT DO YOU THINK WOULD HAPPEN?
YOU SUPPORT THE LAW THAT WOULD
CALL FOR IT.
>> WHAT I AM WORRIED ABOUT IS
WHEN THE CONSTITUTION WAS MADE
AND WHEN THE SECOND AMENDMENT
WAS MADE, IT STATED THAT, OF
COURSE, THE SECOND AMENDMENT,
BUT LET'S TALK ABOUT WHEN IT WAS
MADE.
THAT WAS WHEN ASSAULT RIFLES,
YOU HAVE TO TAKE SEVERAL MINUTES
TO RELOAD AN ASSAULT RIFLE.
NOW IT'S SEVERAL SECONDS.
[OVERLAPPING TALKING].
LET'S REVIEW THAT LAW AGAIN.
>> Tucker: OKAY.
YOU KEEP DODGING MY QUESTION.
I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT.
WE ARE GETTING TO A POINT WHERE
ACTUAL LEGISLATION HAS BEEN
SPONSORED AND WILL BE BEGIN
SAYING THE GOVERNMENT NEEDS TO
TAKE PEOPLE'S WEAPONS BY FORCE.
IF YOU REALLY CARE ABOUT
PREVENTING DEATHS, I WONDER IF
YOU ARE CONCERNED EVEN A LITTLE
BIT THERE MIGHT BE A VIOLENT
REACTION TO THAT.
?
IS CRAZY TO SUGGEST?
>> THAT'S NOT CRAZY.
BY FORCES NOT WHAT WE WANT TO
DO.
>> Tucker: THAT'S WHAT THE LAW
SAYS.
>> I AM TALKING ABOUT SAYING
ANYTHING ABOUT FORCE.
>> Tucker: DID YOU SUPPORT THE
LAW SAYING THE STATE SHOULD
SEIZE AND TAKE POSSESSION OF
THESE GUNS?
>> I SUPPORT SAVING LIVES.
THAT'S BAN ON ASSAULT RIFLES.
THESE KIDS ARE OUT HERE AND THEY
ARE SAYING WE NEED TO PUT A BAN
ON ASSAULT RIFLES.
>> Tucker: WE ARE BOTH AGAINST
KILLING.
I HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT THE
EFFECTS OF THE LAW THAT YOU
SUPPORTED BUT DON'T WANT TO
ADDRESS.
THE OVERWHELMING MAJORITY OF GUN
DEATHS IN THIS COUNTRY ARE
CAUSED BY HANDGUNS, NOT BY
ASSAULT RIFLES.
THAT'S A TINY PERCENTAGE.
WHY ARE WE BANNING THE GUNS THAT
CAUSES A SMALL PERCENTANG EVER
KILLINGS BUT LEAVING THE GUNS
THAT CAUSE THE MAJORITY LEGAL?
>> I UNDERSTAND WHAT YOU ARE
SAYING.
YOU MAY SAY IT'S A SMALL
PERCENTAGE.
>> Tucker: IT IS.
>> WHEN IT'S YOUR BROTHER OR